[Music]
oh this one's kind of sad
no let's make it happy we'll make it
happy well i don't know
this one's kind of crazy so this guy a
29 year old
romanian pop like up and coming pop star
he that's pretty funny so far romanian
pop star yeah
and i think of comrade detective so he
was listening to loud music in his car
he was live streaming himself and he was
in the car with his wife who's 24
and at one point in the live stream
the wife stops over like a railroad
track
so she's driving she's driving yeah and
she kind of looks both sides
but she didn't notice the oncoming train
and so you see
tavi scream and react
to the train and then it collides why
did she stop in the middle of the tracks
we don't know they don't have the ding
ding
ding ding we're going to make this fun i
don't know but
i'm going to show you guys the video
clip
guys so they didn't make it
so tavi the husband he
didn't make it [ __ ] sakes the wife is in
critical condition [ __ ]
so we could kind of make fun of one not
the other [ __ ] parks in the middle of
train tracks like that
and not see a train maybe she didn't i
mean she didn't park i think she was
trying to be cautious and look for the
one direction
trains are [ __ ] loud and she forgot
to check for the we don't know what kind
of train it is it could have been a
small it's not japan it's not a [ __ ]
bullet train yeah what if it's an
electric silent bullet train could have
been electric train very
very silent i never heard a lot of
trains around me are electric right now
see
i've never seen one that's a quiet train
isn't it if you've never heard it you
all the la
all the trains in la or they're electric
yeah those are electric they don't say
choo choo
i thought they say choo choo those are
old oh if you're next to it you hear
that [ __ ] coming
that's some casey jones [ __ ] dumbo
[ __ ] yeah but you hear the the tracks
going
well now they have bells what is it
approaching you
i feel like they add noises to the ones
here but maybe over there they don't
give a [ __ ]
just like the motorcycles the electric
motorcycles they add the noise harley
adds the noise to theirs
[Laughter]
they need to do that for the train they
need to go choo choo
choo boy they need to put just those
annoying mufflers on a [ __ ] train
that's the only thing that needs an
annoying muffler other than that [ __ ]
you for having annoying muffler dude
jesus
oh poor guy dude how are we going to
make this happy
like i said this was
tavi and his wife and we're gonna see
the tragic death
well not the death okay it's gonna stop
before the collision
okay but you could just see what's
leading up to it hey [ __ ]
it's still pretty weird i know i agree
it's really weird i don't like that it's
like faces of death and [ __ ]
i know well we don't see that up until
the face of
faces of put almost death yeah pre-death
kind of
oh man well here we go
is that a song
[Music]
so see she looks both sides but then he
he notices it what was she looking at
what the [ __ ]
it happened that [ __ ] happens well maybe
because it's the two like they go in
different directions and it looks like
she's probably looking at one i don't
know
see this is what i don't understand
right it's like i don't know many places
that
don't block off he's looking on his
phone and [ __ ] too no but like
just while you're driving right how many
places do you know
where they just let trains run back and
forth without blocking off the street
yeah we've gone to multiple countries in
that and i've never seen
one where the ding ding ding ding that
closes
yeah yeah maybe they're on like some
kind of like dirt road
you know that's in like a country
saturday some [ __ ] yeah but they should
have the ding ding ding they should have
the ding ding no
you guys want to see the aftermath not
really but yeah
this is what the car looked like after
oh
i'm surprised there's that much car and
they're saying that authorities really
struggled to get the pair out of the car
bro did the top peel off
what did they cut it off when they came
to rescue them will you use the jaws of
life kind of
stuff the only reason why i think like i
can kind of
relate or understand obviously we don't
know the full story but i'm just
assuming here and filling in the holes
with my own information
um is remember the one time i we got in
a crash
and the car hit you oh yeah okay so what
happened on that one is i was gonna make
a left turn going to our place when we
slept in monterey park
i was gonna make a left turn uh i'm at a
it's a green light i'm waiting for all
these cars to pass by
bart starts talking to me about this
mural on the wall
and then beautiful mural though so then
i look
and then um the light started changing
so then i was like oh
[ __ ] i'm in the middle of the street so
i wanted to get out but i didn't even
realize that there was a car coming this
way because i was so focused on that
[ __ ] thing and as soon as i looked
i was like oh [ __ ] so then i went and
then that's when we
we like they hit me can you believe the
audacity versus she put
me between her and the other car that
was coming
i said i was making a left turn
purposely
you know what he did he was like he
tried to to brace
so he like put his shoulder into the
[ __ ] door because he wanted to stop
the
truck the minute i saw the car coming at
us i was like
what do i do brace for this [ __ ]
toward it like a football hockey
[ __ ] dude i don't know my brain
just took off
here yeah that one yeah do that [ __ ]
that's it
that's the most reaction instead bart's
like maybe this will work
well the car is coming this way the car
is coming this way so i'll protect you
yeah i'll try to protect everything yeah
so true
that is the lens you could be through
too that's true i mean what would you
rather have him do
you know he's all like he puts the chair
down
i'd be like [ __ ] we're breaking
up
but what if he did this
i'm barney's journey goes
no it's all about it can you see the
mural though
sorry we lived in monterey park and
there's this bank and he goes oh
[ __ ] that's what monterey park used to
look like but i'm in the middle of the
[ __ ] it was like a mosaic
[Laughter]
so what if he unbuckled and jumped in
the back seat
because that's the way heading towards
the trunk would you have enough time
the cars come in bla bla and then you
[ __ ] matrix your way backwards and
then he kicks me forward
and then i pick her up and put her in
the passenger seat
did you get hurt no like the airbags
like all went off and [ __ ] but no one
got hurt thank god
so what was that [ __ ] time when bart had
a [ __ ] neck brace for jk newsstand oh
yeah that was the funniest [ __ ]
was that from lifting that's lifting
that's from lifting that's for lifting
yeah so you got more injured from
lifting than a car accident
yeah wild [ __ ] bracing yourself for
the car
it's bad though oh my god i had to have
another one i slept weird you know
sometimes you sleep weird
and your neck's all stiff and then so
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'll go
work out and then you go work out you're
like oh [ __ ] it's really bad now
oh [ __ ] damn so how'd you do against the
truck though
you're bracing for it did you [ __ ] up
the truck yeah what happened
i mean i would have died if it was going
faster but it was
like the car she was trying to slam on
the brakes too
so just kidding was you guys in my honda
accord
i didn't hit it on your side it didn't
hit you it hit me it hit it hit my side
that's why you got to get a bulletproof
car what's what's your
cyber truck
oh wait damn the windows are really good
i thought they were doing that for [ __ ]
for joe that was [ __ ] hilarious i
can't believe that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] fun it's like a
shatter proof
for from him being a troll though i i
thought that that was staged
and then it happened twice like no way
he's trolling
so goddamn good that's great marketing
yeah it went everywhere nobody
didn't see it wow it's the [ __ ] so yeah
i get
if if it happened that way where she's
only paying attention to this
bro you know what else happened i don't
want to say anything though i don't say
anything
then don't say it but the car that
crashed into us
yes the driver uh oh here we go was a
lady
the driver of the honda accord in our
collision
was a lady is that so important there's
another driver
in this story i've been waiting to say
that
but i decided not to gender was that
driver i'm not gonna say anything like i
said
you know i'm gonna stick to my guns i'm
gonna stick to my guns and not say what
else but if you were bracing then i
doubt you were holding the steering
wheel
exactly this passenger okay wait a
minute way to [ __ ]
even the car that people okay even the
car that t-boned us was
fine but i'm not going to say it like i
said just just just figuring it out yeah
i don't know but um your insurance does
not increase
because you live in an area where
there's a ton of women now does it
yeah good point i don't think so when i
lived in monterey park
oh yeah that's a predominantly asian
but they use they use it what a race or
whatever why yeah
why aren't we not separate or does it
just happen
it's not asian it's not because it's
asian because there's a lot more
collisions there
because there's asians goddammit thank
you
but let me tell you something in west la
i realized there is
a whole bunch of different people a
whole different culture
that is a worse drive us it is
people who think they're more important
than other people oh yeah they're the
worst
[ __ ] i'm on the phone i'm on a 10
million dollar deal [ __ ] you
those [ __ ] they drive horrible hey
buddy get out of the way
they talk exactly like that yeah they
have a cigarette and they always flip
you off
as they're taking off
the wannabe wolf of wall street dudes
and their wives that they cheat on
yeah yeah with a red range rover
with the matching leather red thing and
she has like a caring cut
she's like the most evolved karen like
walmart karen
wishes she was rolls royce karen you
know what i mean yeah what's up what's
the caring cut now
it's like the first thing the bobs oh
the bobs yeah i could i could show you
like it's like this it's like
like that okay but the cairns are
evolving these days like that and then
it's usually
it's like long here and it goes up here
and it goes up like that
and sometimes but the walmart karen
they'll have a more cheaper version they
have ice tips it looks like yeah
it looks like a like a it's like a
terrier on this yeah
yeah and uh for the record bart's the
worst driver compared to the uh us two i
haven't gotten in an accident since then
um and he's gotten several accidents
bart is a horrible driver he has nothing
to say well i was gonna say something i
don't get cancer so that's okay oh there
we go
good job good job out of all the things
you've already said
well you're already canceled for the
date next time
for saying that better i i propose a new
way of doing
sad news okay i'm gonna get trampolines
and we're going to jump while we say
that or the yoga balls those were fun
when i had it where'd it go
i don't know i took it home to practice
i'm not trying to make much bounce
real quick though as a motorcyclist uh
and i i look up a lot of like different
stats and [ __ ]
people just don't notice things when
they look out their window and like even
when they check
if it's not a car so like any other
thing
like like they're so used to looking for
cars so she didn't register the train
she's just yeah i think a lot of times
you'll look but then a lot of times if
like the first thing you'll notice right
away if it's a car
the other other things it takes a little
bit longer for your brain to register
because you're
you don't you're not around it as much
so you don't look for as much i register
homeless men with samurai swords
so it also like i rewatched the video a
few times and
right here when she looks towards where
the train is
i have a feeling his body kind of
covered it
he's still fat she probably saw him and
he's not calling her i'm just saying
he's like
just a body there just a solid thing
that got in the way
you know who should have not seen what
was going out the window i was in k-town
recently there was this woman sitting in
a car
there was a homeless man right next to
the car he was standing like this
and he was just taking the biggest [ __ ]
it was just going down and you can hear
her go
ah it sounded like someone just was just
murdered it was crazy well there was
remember that lady that got a bucket
full of [ __ ] dumped on her by a homeless
dude remember that story
no i did not edit that one well that one
was insane
that happened but really quick before we
end this video
i just wanted to mention um back to the
story here
with this guy he said that one month
before it says that one month before he
died
he had posted a message to his followers
on facebook saying
one day the wrong train will take you to
the right destination
isn't that crazy jesus that's more crazy
ironic i know rest in peace
[Music]
you